as 2019 comes to an end we here at
GameSpot want to take a look back at the
highs and lows of the year and we're
gonna focus on individual platforms
before we get into our nominees game of
the year and we're starting out with
Xbox Peter highs and lows surface level
what do you think of Xbox this year
highs were high and the lows were low
you know what I think it was a
transitionary year for Xbox but I think
a lot of exciting things hat still
happened and we're talked about and 2019
is a good year for 2020 for Xbox if you
know what I'm saying yeah laying down
the groundwork laying down the tracks
getting ready for 2020 Jordan what about
you I'm pretty much in the exact same
boat this is weird to have a
transitionary period so late in the
console cycle but happy that Xbox is
finally showing some good stuff as after
a few years of kind of emptiness yeah
last year they acquired a good amount of
studios in this year they only added to
that with Double Fine and obsidian two
massive studios I think that people are
very excited to see unwell maybe not
everyone's excited to see under Xbox but
there's a lot of promise with those
studios I mean especially with outer
worlds which released earlier this year
which got great reviews all around
yeah absent they're doing I mean pillars
of eternity to Cup last year was
excellent I can't remember that was last
year the year before it doesn't matter
it was excellent out of worlds was
excellent to see what they're gonna do
with Microsoft I think they're gonna
inject some you know some fresh energy
under the xbox flag which kind of needed
a it's nice just to see that Xbox is
allowing them to experiment grounded
that weird kids survival game yeah but
we're talking a lot about the future
however 2019 did have a big game for
Microsoft in the form of Gears of War 5
or Gears 5 as they've kind of been
rebranding it a little bit to give it a
fresh start because I think gears 4 was
fine it was pretty safe and Gears 5
seems to be the right step or the right
direction to take that series with these
more open areas and bundling that in
with games past two seemed like a big
win for them I say at the very least it
showcases a willingness to
adapt and explore new avenues they could
have just made gears 5 another very
linear cover based shooter and it
probably would have sold decent or
something like that but they decided to
like you know let's just make an
open-world component to this and it
happened to do well so I'm hopeful that
this allows Microsoft to encourage its
other first party studios to be a bit
more experimental with the games that
they want to create and not stick to
their guns so to speak and we kind of
see that again with obsidian with
grounded and a ninja theory with a
bleeding edge they're kind of outside of
their wheelhouse it's intriguing to see
what they're gonna do with that yeah
yeah it'll be interesting to see how
those shake out but that's not the only
exclusive that came out in 2019 we also
had crackdown 3 which is a game that I
have it baffles me that that came out
this year it seems like it came out a
while ago it was it was rough I think it
had some fun moments but well if
anything I think the fact that they were
able to a Trojan horse some X cloud you
know technology in there for the
multiplayer there's a pretty interesting
showcase of what can happen when you
have a bit more power to run things say
like a physics system and have
completely destructible environments in
a multiplayer setting because
traditionally if you're trying to do
that between consoles that's gonna be
really difficult to have all those
things sync up I think but doing it
localized like that and pulling it off
is that was pretty cool honestly whether
or not there was a lot of fun to play
from a technical perspective I found
that very interesting
did you talk a lot about it but I
noticed I mean that brings us to game
game past which both of those games are
able to play day one if you had game
paths and as long as you paid what $10 a
month about good access to those games
day one as well as over a hundred games
by now both big and small and I think
it's definitely given a good opportunity
for indie games that a lot of people
probably normally wouldn't buy or pay
for at least gives them gives them a
shot yeah and say it's nice just there
they're rotating the roster of games
like some games are taken away to add
new ones so it's not cluttered like the
Microsoft Marketplace and Nintendo eShop
like we actually get to see new indie
games get featured in their first few
weeks when they're added to the service
and eventually they're rotated out but
it's a nice thing to just see that
they're kind of doing that whole Xbox
360 arcade game thing again where they
were highlighting specific indie games
and kind of boosting their sales
especially something like outer wilds
which is a game that I know a lot of
people were interested in and it got
very good reviews but I don't think that
would have reached nearly as many people
if there wasn't like he was like a if
there wasn't game game pass in order to
kind of try to claim paying for Gears 5
and outerworld and you're getting stuff
like utter wilds creature in the well
Blair which kind of for free so to speak
and to be able to experiment with the
sort of games that you even play or give
a chance to play like I don't know how
you could ever mark it outer wilds and
bring someone into that right if it
wasn't something that they could
conveniently just play I mean I guess
word of mouth helps but I mean on games
game pass is just huge yeah totally we
also did a huge profile with Phil
Spencer this year and I think we got a
lot of interesting stuff out of that we
really did I think chiefly you know as
the headline said for the main piece
like Phil Spencer is exactly who you
think he is and you know he is one of
the reasons that Microsoft and Xbox seem
like such a promising place for games
and the gaming experience to grow in the
years to come and you could you could
always say well that's just great
marketing we spend enough time with the
guy and you know we had enough organic
experiences where I mean if they were
coordinated for our benefit that would
have been super impressive but like you
know we were with Phil Spencer when he
ran into people that he plays games with
on Xbox Live these are just other Xbox
users they're not like executives at
other companies for example and he has a
friendship with these people and it just
we we really got the sense that he wants
to connect people to games and connect
developers to players and that's the
direction they're moving in with
everything and yeah if you go check out
that stuff you'll sort of get a sense of
what I'm talking about
he's Xbox is in great hands with him
yeah we've that more than ever and you
can even kind of see it right with how
they've been pushing Crosse place so
hard over the past couple years and I
think what even this year's Sony finally
caved and there are some some cross play
games that they have as well which is
which is interesting and I and I think
Xbox definitely kind of took the lead on
that anyway which is that like people
playing Minecraft on a bunch of
different different platforms together
is really interesting exciting and that
brings us to the elite 2 controller
which I don't think anyone was really
expecting
however it's it's a pretty looking thing
yeah it's another excellent looking and
I haven't used it but I'm sure working
piece of hardware she really shouldn't
say that without testing it but I
haven't heard anything bad about it
endorsements 3 ends like it was I mean I
mess or a lot with the first one so just
I didn't get a whole lot of time with
the elite 2 controller but mess around
with it it's like alright this is a
logical next step and it's and I think
they've announced right that that
controller would also be compatible with
Scarlett - it sounds correct I would say
I believe Microsoft just said all Xbox
one controllers are compatible yeah I
mean even if that's not the case right
like you can still use it on PC with the
X cloud stuff when that rolls out
eventually
yeah so that's exciting like I am have
it I do like those totals quite a bit I
mean speaking of X cloud like it hasn't
launched to everyone but there's a
pretty widespread beta out there for X
cloud stuff Microsoft has delivered like
50 games on that service and having used
it really well so I don't know if you
guys have tried it much but just for my
two cents what it's worth that's been
kind of a highlight of the end of the
year for me when it comes to Xbox yeah
and didn't EXO 19 they said that they
were gonna roll game pass into that roll
that into game pass I think it's
brilliant right like if you're paying
the money if there's a game you're
interested in you can try it out for a
little bit if hey you like it download
it and you're all set I don't think
we're ready to embrace game streaming is
like the the sole way to play video
games yet but yeah having it as like a
secondary thing to like your console
you know that's bundled into the same
service as you pay for that's just like
a no-brainer say it's
you might as well just try it if you're
already paying for game path ultimate
yeah exactly right and it might work
better than you thought it would oh yeah
[Laughter]
and then I guess finally that brings us
to accessibility something that
Microsoft is still pushing earlier this
year they released a guidelines
essentially for developers in order to
make their games more accessible as they
tried to add options for people who have
colorblindness add subtitle options for
people who just sit far away from their
screen and just need larger text like me
I tell away I love that outer worlds now
has larger text because I hated having
to sit so close to my monitor but it's
nice to see that Microsoft didn't just
release their adaptive controller last
year in 2018 they're like alright that's
that's good enough we've done our
accessibility part let's just move on
and they're trying to now go on the
other side of things get developers to
make games that are more accessible for
the players who are probably going to be
using that controller yeah it's just
every step of the long the way this year
it just seems like Microsoft understands
that players have needs and those come
in different shapes and forms whether
it's accessibility whether it's the
ability to just play games and be a part
of the console experience they love but
the accessibility stuff is unrivaled and
that's that's hugely commendable mm-hmm
yeah and that stuff isn't standardized
quite yet but I think just having those
guidelines there is a good step towards
that so eventually maybe cuz like I'm
sure developers just don't even think
about this stuff sometimes right it's
probably not that they had any intention
to do the opposite of make their game
accessible but yeah having this gives
them a good blueprint right yeah at
least something to think about yeah
what are out over all though so overall
how are you feeling I feeling really
positive about the future but if I but
you know if I talk about 2019 like it
didn't involve me playing xbox games and
involved me thinking about Xbox but in a
positive light okay now say I did play
Xbox a lot in 2019 primarily for game
passed like that's its selling point and
so I'm hopeful for 2020 going forward
but overall like just compared to Sony
and Nintendo it's just kind of an
average year
and the grand scheme of things great
year for Microsoft great year for Xbox
one but just kind of middle-of-the-road
kind of overall yeah I'd agree well they
have done a lot of exciting things with
game paths and accessibility at the end
of the day what I'm personally looking
for are new games new experiences that
are that are interesting different not
just halos and gears of wars over and
over again and kind of didn't really
scratch that itch entirely but like you
were saying with all the studios they've
acquired hopefully 2020 will be very
exciting for Microsoft biggest fingers
crossed